in this video we'll talk about plasmid
DNA isolation via the alkaline lysis
method
plasmid DNA is a really important tool
in molecular biology lab people who are
cloning the gene they need to propagate
the gene in a bacteria by transformation
reaction if you want to know more about
transformation video is there in I
button or description but anyway
propagating the plasmid amplifying the
plasmid or storing the plasmid is really
important
so overall in this video we'll try to
understand how from bacterial cells one
can chemically isolate the plasmid in a
purified form
so there are two methods by which one
can do that there are column based
purification which use the principle of
affinity chromatography for purifying
and there is also chemical purification
which use fundamental uh chemical based
approach to purify the plasmid obviously
you can understand the first one is kid
based and customized so this is more
costly whereas the second chemical
purification or alkaline lysis is an
inexpensive method it's very cheap
but very efficient
so in this alkaline lysis method you
start with solution number one in a
moment I'll tell you the composition but
you first resuspend the bacterial uh
cells
by
resuspension buffer
in the resuspension buffer you have Tris
EDTA EDTA is very important because
because it chillates divalent metal ions
such as calcium and magnesium which are
also important for dnases so by
chelating these divalent ions you can
also chillate DNA's activity
also if you remove these calcium and
magnesium it would destabilize the
membranes as well glucose is also added
in this solution to maintain the
osmolarity and ensures the cells doesn't
prematurely burst
so overall the resuspension buffer has a
composition like this so in order to
prepare 100 ml of resuspension buffer or
solution one you need to add all these
components glucose Tricia EDTA water and
have to adjust the volume till 100 ml
then the important part is the alkaline
lysis in order to take the plasmid out
of the cell you have to realize the cell
to take out the plasmid and this lysis
step is performed by solution number two
this solution like Number Two Can Be
Imagined as a lysis buffer which
contains sodium hydroxide and SDS so
obviously by presence of sodium
hydroxide you can understand this
particular solution is highly alkaline
and that gives us the name the alkaline
lysis
anyway the alkaline lysis step is
performed by solution to whose
composition is exactly mentioned here
but I'll tell you what exactly happens
after putting the alkaline lysis
solution the solution to you mix it
gently and wait a little bit of time
such that the lysis can happen in this
step
first of all NaOH loosens up the cell
wall SDS pops hole in the membrane and
that releases the overall chromosome of
bacteria and also the plasmid DNA in the
solution
now also the DNA gets denatured because
all the interaction between the DNA is
the base pairs the hydrogen bonds are
now disrupted because there is an
alteration in PH in the solution right
and this is not favorable for hydrogen
bond formation because it is highly
alkaline
so DNA gets denatured particular point
of time if you take it
um
take the solution and open the tube you
would see strand like appearances coming
out of the tube
now the next step is neutralization this
extremely alkaline environment has to be
neutralized
and this neutralization is done by
potassium acetate
an acetic acid
obviously by putting acid you can
neutralize the base
so it forms a salt known as potassium
doticile sulfide sulfite with the SDS
which is present in the alkaline lysis
solution and this is an insoluble salt
so after putting this solution three
what happens is you see cardi
precipitate like stuff appearing in the
tube which are highly insoluble you can
visually see them
so
then you wait sometime and then
centrifuge them
now once you add the neutralization
buffer the waiting is important because
you want to wait for precisely the time
that would allow the circular DNA or the
plasmid to denature but it doesn't give
enough time for the denatured
cellular DNA or the chromosomal DNA to
denature so you have to ensure that okay
renaturation happens only for the
plasmic DNA so the timing is critical in
this step after that one should one
should centrifuge them
and precipitate this insoluble
substances the salt of
doticile sulphate so after that what
happens the aqueous portion is taken out
and
along with this aqueous portion 0.6
volume of isopropanol is added to
precipitate the plasmic DNA which we
which is supposed to be in this solution
now isopropanol makes the DNA unhappy so
isopropanol first
uh
performs bonds with the DNA DNA doesn't
interact with the water so it's not any
more solubilized it's now precipitated
after ultimately it forms a pellet after
isop isopropanol precipitation and this
pellet can be washed again by uh ethanol
washing so ethanol is added the
precipitation is again done
so ultimately after that
the pellet is dried and resuspended in
nucleus free water or let's say some
Tris buffer this plasmid one once
isolated can be stored in minus 80 or
minus 20 degree Centigrade for years
now how do you know the plasmid is good
quality that you have isolated so you
can run those plasmid in a gel and it
should show you several bands I mean
there are many outcomes possible like
bands correspond to nicked plasmid
linear plasmid super coil or circular
closed circular plasmid
the predominant form that you should be
expecting is basically the super coiled
one and that's why you should be getting
the thickest band in the super coil
region and other bands should be very
faint
anyway you can also check the quantity
of plasmid that how much is the yield of
this isolation process so one can put a
one microliter plasmid there and
ultimately one can check the absorbance
at 260 by 218 nanometer it should come
around like more than 500 nanograms per
microliter for a good yield and a 260
280 ratio should be 1.8 for a pure DNA
if this ratio is not proper then there
could be a problem or contamination in
your plasmic DNA by looking at these
parameters you can understand how good
the isolation is
you can find more flashcards and notes
in my Facebook Facebook page and you can
find more notes in Instagram page anyway
you can uh support the channel via super
thanks you can use paytm PayPal or UPI
for pain see you in next video